why are we obsessed with ugly sweaters
there are a few times a year when you're
encouraged to dress as ridiculously as
possible like free burrito day at
Chipotle Coachella and ugly sweater
parties the gaudy tradition has gone
from strictly DIY to t.j.maxx ugly
holiday sweaters are a multi-million
dollar industry benefiting small
businesses big-box stores and office
holiday parties all across the state
but how did something so tacky become a
holiday tradition the outdated looks of
80s and 90s eventually made an ironic
return thanks to the tendency of
trend-setting hipsters to resurrect fads
searches for the term ugly sweater
reached an all-time high in 2014 more
than doubling from the year before and
now some stores are moving millions of
let's get elf duck shirts a year
retailers like Macy's Target and Walmart
jumped on the trend around 2015 with
shelves full of mass-produced styles but
big box stores haven't completely
squashed their handmade competition Deb
Rodham sells hundreds of tacky holiday
sweaters out of her home so I wouldn't
even call my sweaters ugly I think
they're they're tacky but mainly they're
just full of life and they've got
they're full of color and I love it
thanks to the internet her hobby
transformed into a fully stocked studio
filled with five hundred and fifty
sweaters ready to ship I have found that
the more time you take the more stuff
that's on the sweater I can make more
money so for instance a Barbie sweater
that is just a plain with the hurt with
the North Pole and the gingerbread felt
gingerbread I sell for $43 all the time
but once I added the glitzy tree and
other Barbie two sets of lights that
retails for $119 I think that's what
they want the whole it's the whole
package it's the it's the party it's the
popularity it's the prize at the end you
know everybody wants to be the one the
talk of last night sweater party yet out
it's not just your co-workers gunning
for that prize it feels like every brand
from Taco Bell to Captain Morgan
incorporated ugly sweaters into its
marketing strategy not to mention the
spread of ugly sweater themed things
like Krispy Kreme donuts and skittles
packaging and running shoes the trend
just keeps picking up speed which might
mean that it's not a trend at all and
that's the ugly truth
you